Congressman John Conyers stepped aside
as a top Democrat on the House Judiciary
Committee under intense pressure Nancy
Cordes is on Capitol Hill where an
ethics investigation of sexual
harassment allegations against Conyers
is underway Nancy good morning good
morning Nancy Pelosi said yesterday
there's a refreshing new zero-tolerance
attitude here on Capitol Hill but then
she declined to come down hard on one of
her own members and that surprised even
some Democrats John Conyers is an icon
in our country he's done a great deal to
protect women Democratic Leader Nancy
Pelosi was cautious Sunday when asked
about allegations against Michigan's
John Conyers do you believe John Conyers
is I don't know who they are do you they
have not really come forward and and
that gets you don't know if you believe
the accusations what that's for the
ethics committee to review but I believe
he understands what is at stake here and
he will do the right thing
hours later Conyers announced he would
be stepping down as the top Democrat on
the House Judiciary Committee though he
vehemently denied the allegations leader
Pelosi followed with a more forceful
statement saying no matter how great an
individual's legacy it is not a license
for harassment the House Ethics
Committee opened an investigation into a
pair of allegations against Conyers last
week including revelations that his
office paid a former staffer more than
27,000 dollars to settle a complaint
that staffer said she was fired for
refusing Conyers sexual advances legal
documents published by BuzzFeed news
detail multiple allegations by female
staff members of unwanted touching and
romantic advances one of his anonymous
accusers has released a statement
through her lawyer asking to be released
from her confidentiality agreement she
says if Conyers can speak freely about
what did or didn't happen then she
should be able to do the same flag
Nancy Cordes thank you very much